字幕: Emi Atarashi
校正: Yoshiaki Yamagami
通常このような途上国の現場に立って
仕事をしている者として
肌で感じるエミッションの
脅威について
今日は 皆さんと
共有をさせて頂きたいと思います
そして エミッションの中でも
今日は 私の主に担当している仕事である
ゴミとエミッションについて
お話をしていきたいと
いうふうに思います
まず皆さんに 世界のゴミを
ご紹介していきたいと思います
一番初めにご紹介するのは
これはアフリカの
エチオピアという国の
首都のアディスアベバという所にある
ゴミの山です
高さは 一番高いところで
50メートルぐらい
下の面積はですね
42ヘクタールもある―
アフリカの中では
そこそこ大きいゴミの山です
もうちょっと近づくと
こんな感じです
いつも崩落をしているという
大変危険なゴミ山でもあります
こちらがケニアのゴミ山
そして次が
アジアに参りまして
これはインドネシアのジャカルタの
ちょっと外れの所にあるゴミの山です
続きまして今度は
ネパールの首都カトマンズ
カトマンズ渓谷の外れにある
山の斜面を削って作ったゴミの山でして
これは高さが80メートルぐらいある
私が見た中でも 多分
１番か２番に高いゴミ山であります
続きまして
最後にご紹介するゴミ山が
これはミャンマーのヤンゴンのゴミ山です
今 ご覧頂きましたように
ゴミというのは
アフリカだろうが アジアだろうが
大体どこの国でも
同じような姿をしていますし
ゴミの中身って言うんですか
「組成」って言うんですけれども
ほぼ一緒です
こういうものが
残念ながら どんどん増えている
世界中の都市に
ゴミ山というのがあって
例えば インドであれば
3000以上あると言われていますし
インドネシアでも 2000ぐらい
中国でも 2000ぐらい
タイで 1500ぐらい
アメリカでも 1500ぐらいある
というふうに言われております
残念ながら
そのゴミ山の数というのは
世界で増加を続けているというところ
原因は 私たちの生活
人間活動にほかありません
はい そしてですね
このゴミの処理の方法なんですけれども
日本では ゴミというのは
大体きちんと回収されて
そして 焼却をして
その灰になった本当にわずかの
残りだけが
ゴミの埋立場に
持って行かれるんですけれども
実は 世界の大部分 ７割近くは
ゴミというのは 焼却されずに
そのまま埋立場に持って行かれます
先進国であっても 途上国でも
同じです
もちろん先進国を中心に
「衛生埋立」といって
きちんと衛生的に管理をされて
安全に転圧をして
減量して
きちんとリサイクルもして っていう
埋立場もありますけれども
でも 残念ながら大部分は
全く処理をされずに
私は「ゴミ山」と
分かりやすく呼んでおりますけれども
いわゆる「野積み」と言われる
ただただ堆積していく
そして それが
10年 20年 30年経って行くというものが
世界に今現存するゴミ山のほとんどです
そして 皆さんご存じのように
開発途上国を中心に
世界の人口は増え続けております
そして世界では
地方・農村の人口が増えているのではなくて
都市の人口ばかりが増えております
なので都市化率も
どんどん上がっているということですね
2050年以降もこのように
ずっと増えていくと
いうふうに言われております
そして この人口増加とほぼ
正比例するように
世界で排出されるゴミの量というのも
増えております
残念ながら 2050年以降も
このオレンジの線ですね
地域別になっておりますけれども
ずっと増えていく
というふうに言われております
これが
ゴミ問題というのが
きちんと認識されながらも
解決を難しくしている―
もう ただただ
増えていくのでですね
その一因であります
もう１つ
最近分かってきたことといたしまして
先ほど竹村先生のお話にも
ありましたけれども
メタンガスとか CO2とか
いわゆる世界の「温室効果ガス」と
言われているもののほぼ１割以上は
このようなゴミ山から排出されている
ということも分かってきております
このような状況で
ゴミ山が増えているわけですから
もう大問題だ
ということなんですね
これに解決方法はないのかと
ソリューションはないのかと言ったら
もちろん
そういうことはありません
今日は せっかく ここ福岡の会場で
この TEDx を開催しておりますし
皆さん 福岡にゆかりのある方ばかりだと
思いますので
この福岡が誇る
素晴らしい環境技術をご紹介しながら
続きをお話したいと思います
これは福岡市の西区
もうちょっとで糸島っていうところにある
福岡市のゴミの埋立場です
福岡市の管理と管理維持が
大変すばらしいので
パッと見 どこにゴミがあるのか
全く分からないと思いますけれども
この辺で 埋め立てられています
これは「福岡方式」と言いまして
英語で “Fukuoka Method” と
言うんですけれども
今からもう50年近く前
1970年代に
福岡市そして福岡大学の共同研究によって
開発された ゴミの埋め立て技術です
ほぼ 日本で初めてできた
埋め立てのきちんとした技術なんですね
好気性の微生物を活用して
ゴミを分解していくというものです
現在では 日本の
これが環境省で採用された日本の
スタンダードのゴミの埋め立ての
方法となっておりまして
日本の自治体の７割から８割は
この福岡方式を採用しています
そしてこの福岡方式は
開発途上国にもたくさん移転をされていまして
今 現在 21カ国で採用されて
普及をされているということです
なぜ この福岡方式が
途上国にも人気かと言いますと
これを造る為には
もちろん
ここまで美しくきちんと造ろうと思えば
数百億円かかるわけですけれども
開発途上国で予算がなくても
低予算でも
あるいは
高度な土木のスキルがなくても
ローコストでシンプルなテクノロジーでも
できるということ
そして 先ほどご紹介したような
もう何十年もゴミが堆積して
大きなゴミ山になってしまった途中からでも
福岡方式を採用することによって
改善が図られるということが
人気の１つの理由だ
というふうに思います
そして世界のゴミ山はですね
昨今 このように
このゴミの下の方の層に
いっぱいメタンガスが発生して
それがトラップされているんですけれども
それに火が付いたりして
こうやって火災を起こしたりということが
よく発生するようになりました
またメタンガスが爆発を起こして
土砂崩れを起こしたりとか
近隣の集落に災害・被害をもたらしたり
ということも増えてまいりました
ちょっと分かりづらいんです
これさっき―
冒頭にご紹介したエチオピアの
ゴミの山の
山のてっぺんに立って
撮っている写真なんですけれども
ここのゴミの山の一辺が
ガス爆発を起こして
崩落をいたしました
その結果ですね
その下にあった集落が
こうやって下敷きになって
多くの犠牲者を出すという事故が
何年か前に発生いたしました
ゴミ山の周辺というのは
このように
「ウェイスト・ピッカー」と言われる
ゴミを拾うことによって生活をしている人たちが
たくさんいるんです
ここのゴミ山にも
2000人位の人がいたんですけれども
そのうち200人の人が
下敷きになって亡くなった
そういう大災害が起きて初めて政府は
我々のような国連機関に
支援を要請してきて
その支援要請を受けて
私たちは 緊急改善事業を
することになりました
その時に
福岡方式をもともと1970年代から
開発されている―
福岡市のゴミの状況も
これと大差なかった頃から
開発をしておられる―
先生とか福岡市の環境局のOBの方々と一緒に
ベテランの方々と一緒に
現地に行って改善を図って
このように改善をしていったって
いうことなんですね
先程 お見せした西区のゴミの埋立場と
全然違うじゃないかと
思われるかも知れないんですけど
その基本のメカニズムは これで十分
福岡方式の役割を果たしているんですね
この白い細く見えるのが
これ ここからゴミの層に空気を入れて
そこから微量のCO2を
放出する管なんですけれども
これを続けていくことによって
この半年後には こうやって
緑が復活することになります
要するに
コンポストのような
堆肥のような状態に
ゴミの表層がなるんですね
ここまでなると
これぐらい緑が成ると
メタンガスの濃度も
大体５%以下になっているだろうという
１つの目安にもなって
ここまで来れば 安全ですということが
言えるということです
もう１つ事例をご紹介したいと思います
これは 先ほどご紹介したミャンマーの
ヤンゴンのゴミの処分場です
ここも数年前に
火災が発生いたしまして
４週間燃え続けるという
大火災になりました
メタンガスが燃える火災なので
消防車が水をかけても消えないんですね
やっぱりゴミを改善していかないと
絶対に消えない
そういうことで
２度と火災が起こらないような措置をして
ファイアーウォールって言うんですけれども―
トラックや重機が通るような
この通路をきちんと確保して
たとえ ここで火災が発生しても
隣には延焼しないようにする
ここにも そのガスを抜くための管を
たくさん敷設して
そして これから１年半後ぐらいには
このように緑に覆われるゴミ山に
なっていったということなんです
先ほど
世界の温室効果ガスは
10%がゴミ山から来ているという
お話をいたしましたけれども
福岡方式による技術の改善を行うことで
このようなゴミ山で発生するメタンガスを
40%から50% 削減できるということが
予想されています
この計算は まだ始まったばかりで
これからこのような現場で
検証を重ねて
これからどんどん検証していくものと
思われますけれども
世界から大いに
期待がされているところです
先月エジプトで開催された
COPの会議においても
日本政府と私たち国連ハビタットの
共催の分科会が開催されたんですけれども
その席でも西村環境大臣が
日本はこの福岡方式を用いて
世界各国の支援をこれからも行いたい
ということを
発言してくださいました
今日はですね アフリカやアジアの
ゴミの山をご紹介いたしました
皆さん 我々は基本的に今
日本に住んでいて
確かにこの諸外国でのゴミの問題は
大変だけれども
日本はこういう問題はないし
日本の１人当たりのゴミの排出量は
ちゃんと減っていて
日本は頑張っているではないかと
思われると思うんですね
私もそう思っています
日本は確かに
頑張っているんですけれども
ただ 皆さんご存じのように
日本というのは食料の自給率も大変低い
約７割を海外に依存していたり
私たちが着たり持っている物の
ほとんど全ては
もしかすると外国製品かもしれない
外国から輸入されたものかもしれない
そうするとその過程で 現地で
原材料であるとか
製造されたもの 生産されたもの
加工されたもののうち
使われなくて捨てられたものっていうのは
こういう所に残されていくんですね
残念ながら私も
諸外国のこのようなゴミ山の現場で
そういうものをたくさん見てまいりました
そういうものは 私たちは
決して忘れてはいけないし
やっぱり そういうものを手にする時に
この現状があるということは
きちんと認識しておかなくては
いけないんではないかな
というふうに思っております
そして今 散々申しております
ゴミ山というのは
もう 都市のあらゆるところに
存在しています
なので すぐ近くに集落もあれば
幼稚園小中学校の教育機関なども
あるんですけれども
これはケニアで
事業をやっていた時の写真で
ゴミが飛び散ってる所の
写真なんですけれども
この近くにあった幼稚園の園長先生が
訪ねて来てくださって
この場所でゴミの方向から
風が吹いてくると
園児が必ず何人か
クラスで１人２人は
具合が悪くなって
倒れる子が必ずいたと
今思えば あれはメタンガスだったんですね
というふうに先生がおっしゃる
おかげさまで
この事業をやって改善されてからは
倒れる子はいなくなりましたと
言ってくださいましたけれども
やはりそのときに私は初めて
排出されるメタンの恐ろしさ
というものを実感いたしました
それが私の 多分
COUNTDOWN の始まりだったんじゃないかな
というふうに思っております
これはアフリカの
私の現場なんですけれども
今日 お話を終えて
明日の朝 私は福岡を発って
また ここに戻る予定でございます
今日はどうもありがとうございました
（拍手）